Start
The points we have learned so far are
Scalar function
That is, for a given xy value
Calculate the value of this function
Got a scalar
Just a number
Instead of vector
Today my goal is to make everyone
Have some understanding of vector functions
Then we can understand what is called a linear function
Let me write down several vector functions first.
In fact, let's start with the curve
Let's put this function aside
Don't worry about it for the time being
Suppose now that there is a curve c
Can be parameterized
Specify x=x(t), y=y(t)
The range of t is [a,b]
If I draw it down
Probably this way
It’s very abstract now.
This is not a very specific example
This is the x-axis
This is the y axis
This is the curve. Let this be when t is equal to a
The curve can look like this
I don't know what this means.
Let us say that it is here.
This is the value when t is equal to b.
The abscissa value of this point is x(b)
This will be x-coordination
Calculate the function value of point b
When t is equal to a
In the coordinate system
The abscissa is x(a)
The ordinate is y(a)
We have studied before
This is the general form of describing a parametric curve
a function that represents a curve with two parametric equations
Now all I have to do is
Describe this curve with a vector function
Describe with a vector function, if you don't remember,
Let's review it first.
Suppose there is a vector function r
I marked the vector arrow on r
In many textbooks, vectors are represented in bold.
The scalar will not be bolded
But it is not easy to draw here
So I use arrows to distinguish
Suppose r is a function of t
Let r be the position vector
blank
I especially pointed this out because it is usually said
When people say vector, this one and this one
Considered equal
As long as they have the same direction and size,
The start and end of the vector, ie the position of the vector, do not need to be considered
Just the same direction
Equal size
However, if this is a position vector,
Then the beginning of all vectors must be the origin.
If it is pointed out that this is a position vector,
Means that the position of the vector is uniquely determined
In this question, this is a two-dimensional space.
But the same applies in 3D space.
It can even be 4 degrees, 5 degrees, any dimension space
So when it is pointed out that it is a position vector,
Actually said
A specific point in space.
If the curve is
Position vector function
r is the position vector function for t
Let me change back to pink
This is still green.
Is equal to x(t) multiplied by the unit vector in the x direction
Unit vector has this little caret at the top - one small hat
Just like the little arrow that represents the vector
This means it is a unit vector
Plus y(t) multiplied by j
If this curve is three-dimensional
I also add z(t) multiplied by k
But we are now counting two dimensions
For this question
For any t value, of course, we still have
t is greater than or equal to the limit of a less than or equal to b
This is exactly the same
Let me draw another one
Coordinate System
Origin, coordinate axis
This is the y-axis, the x-axis
This is our first step when you calculate the r value of point a.
Let me write it down
The r value of point a, maybe I should write here
Our position vector is at t
The value of r(a) is equal to x(a) multiplied by
Unit vector along the x direction (horizontal direction)
Add y(a) multiplied by the unit vector in the vertical direction
Direction, or direction of y
What does it look like?
x(a) is represented on the number axis
Then x(a) is multiplied by the unit vector
The unit vector is probably so long
Length is 1,
In this direction
Treat y(a) in the same way
But the base of this vector, this,
If you add the size of these two vectors
Will get r(a)
like this
This is a position vector
This explains why we start from the origin,
Place it in the standard position
This is r(a)
So now how does it change if it grows a bit?
That is, r (a) plus.
Anything, plus Δ,
Or r(a)+h
I use another color to represent
r(a)+h
Plus a small h
In fact, it is (x(a)+h) multiplied by
Unit vector i
Plus y multiplied by (a+h) multiplied by the unit vector
What is the result?
Let's draw a little more along the curve
Going down some
Equivalent to getting the abscissa x+h
The ordinate is y+h
Probably this is
This will be a new vector
Position vector
Not a unit vector
Length is not equal to 1
like this
Use the same color as this
This is r(a)+h
If you continue to increase the value of t
Until you get b. these two position vectors
We continue to mark the points on the curve
I paint this curve in another color.
This curve is like this
It should be the same as the one I painted before.
Let's say r(b),
like this
Like this line
I try to draw it straight
This is
I hope you realize this, these position vectors,
In fact, it is the point in the original curve.
Connect the origin to parameterize it
As we did before
I want to review this simple
Because we have to learn next
Take the derivative of the vector function
I will continue to talk about it in the next section.
End